gang don't forget to pick up your own
deck of the new Ru garbage card game
version 2 it's 50 new questions to find
out if your friends and your family are
trash oh yeah we also have tickets to
our New York show at Town Hall May 9th
available at rug garbage.com it's the
biggest show we've done today get the
tickets let's party gang yeah welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trap
now here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is Ru gerage it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out that
they grow to be classy yeah they're just
a big old piece of trash trash trash
trash I'm your host H Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day the start of
20124 out here in the new edition at
toies she is down in the basement turned
the whole place into a gym she's got the
Boflex she's got the jazzer Sizer she's
got the thing that Suzanne Summers used
to do but plug tighten up the LA sure
shout out to you a couple of kull down
there she's really getting after it man
she got real big plans for 2024 Mak Coos
is coming at you from across the table
here's what we like to call a family
episode ladies and gentlemen just the
boys the bozos and Naomi just the way we
like it he is the CEO of Ru garbage he
is international businessman the black
T-shirt War spills over into 2024 it's
not a war in my head you Kevin James ran
everybody go yourself hey gang thanks
for tuning in we love you first of all
happy freaking New Year
gang hope it was happy and healthy and
all things fun uh first of all please
make sure you R you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are true to ro
cooking then obviously the greatest
website of all time www.patreon.com you
go over there I mean you get multiple
years worth of content if you sign up
today you got to think two episodes a
week times what three two and a half
three years at this point it's like 40
episodes that's like bu my numbers
that's like 70 bajillion hours worth of
content got all the videos all the
travel videos down at Disney yeah
dinosur yeah so if you sign up now you
get the whole backlog of everything
we've ever done it's all on there uh
shout out to you I mean you know uh and
also uh go over to www.u garbage.com you
can get some of the new ay card Gam
that's out there baby fun to play with
family and friends supplies are
dwindling yeah and also uh tickets to
Town Hall New York City New York our
only show currently on the books right
now is New York City Town Hall we're
doing Town Hall in New York City Town
Hall baby bunch of dirt bags like us
stepping it up the Broadway it's a fancy
joint in there having a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinary old
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones the twos the threes and the
fours crosses the te's dots the guys he
does it all give it up for T-Bone
McGruff ands Toby mcmullon what up boys
hey pal happy New Year buddy what up tag
there's somebody out there listening to
this who doesn't know that town hall is
a historic theater and is like yo I got
married at the Town Hall that'd be fun
to see a show there where do they put
the seats yeah these guys got court Dale
new year new us baby let's go and I new
I mean exactly the same that's what I
was going to say I came in here I was
like I'm going to have my ducks in a row
in 2024 I'm going to be eating right get
off the heaters cut back on the sauce
and I've been telling you the same
[__] for 3 years ain't happening we
will be eating right over the next few
months I think yeah we're going to be
off the we're off the road uh you know
for a couple of months which uh it makes
it easier to you know uh couple of good
night sleeps some good night sleeps
maybe some cold plunges some cold
plunges Gary Brea yeah it's the booze
for me on the road I can't not have a
cocktail on the road cookie talk what
that the booze is bad news who's telling
you that who you been talking to my
sponsor the glass of red Wine's good for
the heart sure but the 19 ipas ain't
they're Bud Heavies I'm off the
ipas I will say this I've seen you
drinking warm beer a lot more than I
used to lately this guy no cooler needed
with the kipster these days listen
that's drinking I know what night you
were talking about we were at it we were
doing a show nice little show uh couple
weeks ago we were doing uh we did two
little shows in New York City at the
Triad theater a y and friends and we
brought I brought my own buds cuz I
didn't know what the deal was so I
brought a 12 pack I didn't bring it some
I was drinking radiator beers they were
they were good for the first when
they're in there cold they'll hang for
about an hour that's no I'm telling you
no I got to have them freezing I like a
cold beer yeah yeah sure I mean listen I
don't I'm not it's not like I don't like
I don't I love a cold let me put it you
this way here's the difference I like a
cold beer I can't drink warm beer it
wasn't warm you can get over it it
wasn't cold it wasn't cold that and yes
I can get over it well the see listen
it's a strategy all my booze bags back
me up on this you got a you got a 12pack
not in a not in a cooler not in a bucket
of ice not in the fridge there's that
fuse is lit so I get the first like six
or seven down pretty quick while they're
still cold you're racing the clock here
big guy yeah by then you're all right by
then it don't matter you can hand me
moonshine I don't know what's happening
I'm already [__] drinking turpentine
three sheets to the Wi that kid don't
give a [__] but I'm putting all those
days behind me or I'm telling myself I'm
going to it's the new year baby you got
to try to do something are you not
January is time to lie baby hey last
January I think I went 21 days no booze
I think it was I think there was a a day
or two in there but I did about three
weeks no booze that's pretty good got a
cocktail socially got an [__] I mean
it's the season like a cop go there just
what just talk to my wife with dinner
what are you talking about you get
busted talk to my wife with dinner oh
yeah it's good oh yeah work's going
that's are walking by with like Tre and
Mar man no booze at dinner I'm do I
won't go out I'm asking for the check
with the appetizers at the table I want
to be able to get up and walk away can't
have a zambuka what are we doing here
like a goddamn gentleman sit here listen
this broad
yapping Christ I can't do it uh so
hopefully um obviously we've been ran
ragged the last six months of this year
right and we [__] love it shout out
to the bozos and the homies the tour was
one of the best experiences is best
experiences of Our Lives it was crazy it
was awesome it was so much fun out there
doing the shows meeting everybody but
like we said we're older guys and we
don't live you know it takes a toll on
you the booze the burger I mean we were
on like a two-e run and Tom Cassidy goes
I can't remember if I had a burger last
week I go I've had one every day I've
had a cheeseburger every day we've been
on the road hey Delta don't you go
changing about tell you that so I'm I'm
looking forward to kind of I I'm my not
I I don't like to make resolutions at
all but like you know I definitely want
to get in a better place of you know
shifting better choices less debauchery
just straighten it out a little bit now
that we're off the we're be off the road
I'll be chilling yeah make my breakfast
just for a couple of months and then
we're hitting it heavy in the spring and
the summer it's going to be fun can't
wait to get back out there baby you
cannot say that you think we're
abandoned them or something guys we'll
be back I swear to God we're not going
anywhere and kippy's not going to stop
drinking folks so don't worry about that
it's part of the brand baby he's drunk
right now's he's talking nonsense I this
is a
screwdriver I think we should innovate I
think we should move past the New Year's
resolutions we should do New Year's
revolutions get link up with the CIA
start overthrowing governments I'm
listening what do you got how do you
know we're not already doing that kid
hey man we bought a c
plane anybody know how to fly
it but yeah happy to uh happy to put the
best foot forward this year you know I
tried to MH um I also feel that like uh
I think I know a lot of people get [__]
like to be able to go to like this this
is when everybody gets mad at the gyms
of all these [__] hate those
[__] it's like let them try let
them try they're trying to get better
and yeah they go then yeah they see them
for 3 weeks and it's like see you're in
a plet fitness you [__] loser you're
on the treadmill and jeans right now Z
shut up yeah give me a [__] break oh
God you don't even got to do that [__]
just got to do a little walking little
little slight Twigs little twitch
Twitches twig what are they called yeah
so long so long as you have access to
Modern Medical Science yeah hey what are
you
doing his OIC shooting OIC into your
eyeballs every
day all you got to do is H you know walk
to get the mail Shadow was that big in a
half a cheese steak my New Year's
resolution uhhuh let's go it's like Mark
Maguire giving you batting practice tips
he's like no you watch for the guy's
release and then you know juice yourself
to the kills hey man why's your head so
big shut
up guy's playing with a [__] Rigg
deck over here why do you have acne on
your back and 38
you explain that to me genetic my dad
had it big bne family man I it's I was I
can't remember how old I was when that
all happened but I didn't see any of
that until I saw it what theid the fact
that they were all juicing when like
bonds got so big and Maguire got so big
and that summer they were I still don't
believe it if I'm being honest were
crushing home runs and then all of a
sudden like yeah they're on steroids
like oh [__] yeah they're on steroids
remember I was young enough to still
like one thought he was just getting
after it that's what I figured he's in
the gym he's doing two a days I figured
it was more of like uh there was so much
magic at that time at my age I was you
know 10 11 D baseball loved it oh yeah
they were [__] dude they were
sweeping syringes under the rug left and
right d you how many Big Macs he sold he
was hitting home runs over the over the
Big Mac sign and I think they had a
thing where if you hit one over you got
like a free Big Mac or something like
that I just picture you walking up with
a document it says right here you can't
deny my free big man I'm doing it
now September 1998 this is ridiculous
whatever it was no yeah I I I believed
in it in the moment cuz it was that
magical it was like 41 42 they were like
chasing who hit one last night he hit
another one he hit seven this game what
the
[__] and I was like man it's true it's
like one of those sports miracles find
out they were all [__] on the sauce
on the o
yeah which I I mean you know if you
ain't cheating or you trying that's what
I'm saying that's what we're talking
about TBO all right yeah can I get a
little more
eggnog Crush an old eggnog still still
throwing it back oh man all right how
long do you think you should leave your
uh the the decorations around right now
they should go like early gen that's it
I see New Year's Day always gave me a
little bit of anxiety I mean taking it
down on New Year's to me seems a little
non festive this is the last day of the
season and you're leaving the party
early that's what that Patty's doing
that right now Patty's at home and if I
was at home they'd be they'd be
screaming and get it's all this got to
go no relaxation you got to go back to
school tomorrow [__] nightmares
ripping the tree out this should be a
chill day this should be no we're not
working we're not I'm not unboxing don't
we're not going into the attic into the
basement the storage we're not doing
that we're chilling we'll figure that
out later this week but for now we're
[__] chilling the presents are still
under the bo there's still some boxes
under the tree wait really I'll do that
yeah no kidding crossover into January
with the tree still up that gives you
the he this is what we're talking about
don't you just say I'm saying you do it
I don't like the way pat patty does it
on New Year's Day which I don't think is
good because you got to go back to
school and work January 2nd is into
January and you said that gives you the
heebie jeebies that's no good it should
be like the 27th 28th get that all
cleaned up you're nuts that is [__]
so you can enjoy your your your New
Year's no you enjoy the tree you're
still in the there's so much buildup to
that what do you mean why can't you
enjoy the [__] New Year's with the
tree there how you going to take the
tree down the next day when everyone's
at work on the second doing that on a
Tuesday or something you go down on the
third the second or third that doesn't
matter nah Patty's freaking out she got
the Easter [__] up you're taking your
[__] down on the
27th no she I told you she T I said I'd
like to she takes down on the and it's
[__] I'm saying the 27th is nuts 28th
29th how about that that's my birthday
man I'm not working on my birthday not
working on not working on the Lord's Day
[__] I think weirdo birthday it's a
the first is included in the holiday
season if it was like Hanukkah it's
eight nights that's the eighth night you
can't be breaking down on the eighth
night okay that's the way I look at it
I'll give break down between that is
crazy we used to have a nice uh routine
on New Year's Day cuz all the families
had a day Cousin you know one cousin had
Thanksgiving one cousin had Christmas uh
Christmas Eve night one cousin had
Christmas Day we used to have New Year's
day that was at the Foley household my
mom would make uh her uh strawberry
torte which is like a strawberry tart
with like uh cream cheese filling on top
it was fantastic except for the one year
the dog she freaked the [__] out um and
my dad would make friend FR onion soup
delicious whole family would come over
set all the tables up all over the house
too much onion you're crazy no I'm right
there with you too onion you like french
onion soup I don't know if I've ever had
it but I don't like the looks of it the
onions in there remind me of the aliens
in an xfiles one time and I said no way
I'm never going back the last thing I
want when I'm trying to eatting worms
yeah that's what it feels like sugar
water what I'm trying to nurse a Corbell
hangover is a bowl full of bu of
shoelaces yeah that's nuts oh Corbell is
cheap champagne yeah shout out to
Corbell the glue that holds New Year's
together I do it the plastic cork oh
yeah that sounds great I can't dude I I
take one SI I can't toast with it I I'll
do like a little sip at a wedding when
they're toasting you don't like
sparkling wine I don't like the bubbles
it's too much give me a nice warm
Budweiser now we're talking well no cuz
Corbell is like the middle class Cooks
that's no good Cooks is trash corell's
nice it's like 13
bucks where I come from that's fancy I'm
saying yeah if you're drinking champagne
you might as well be royalty to me and
my family like if you're like oh I do
champagne we'll do mimosas on Easter
morning that's about it yeah champagne
was one glass and then start really
drinking well Corbell is technically a
sparkling wine cuz it's not from the
Champagne region of France this guy
trying to everybody knows that Toby but
it's called champagne anyway
champagne
stamp champag style liquor is there
bubbles in it huh is there bubbles in it
if I mixed them up you would have be
able to tell yeah shut
up everybody started drinking prco that
became the big thing all the
Bru's great I don't know if I've ever I
don't know the difference between any of
it the only time I ever have any of that
stuff it's like at a wedding or a taste
or a brunch some go try that I have a
sip and it's like just get me to the
[__] shot I'm a shot and beer guy
prco is sweeter Cava is drier that's how
it goes great but prco kind of won out
and became the popular thing I saw that
look I thought K yeah you just dropped
the fact that he you gave him [__] for
dropping a fact yeah you're just trying
to be cool like first day [__] everybody
knows that about
champagne [__] what did you think my
response was going to be when you Dro
prco is actuallywe H tell me more
fatty oh please I just told you I hate
this [__] I'm a warm bud
guy [__] breaking my Stones over prco
any who happy New Year's to everybody I
hope you had a happy and safe holiday
season um or if you had a shitty one now
you're out of it and you got [__]
2024 let's go baby we're a couple months
away from Summer yeah let's do this on
Whose clock four months five months six
six actually six and a half seven let's
call it nine either way we're right
there summer Blockbusters heading down
to short let's go Kip this is liquid IV
liquid I visle shout out liquid IV a lot
of New Year's resolutions going around
there people going Full Tilt by the time
uh president thing comes around they're
back on the couch eating potato chips
you don't got to reinvent yourself gang
you know what you got to do you got to
hydrate yourself when you do that liquid
IV workouts it's fantastic you go out
the night before you get all banged up
get all slashed up drinking whiskies and
you're the hydrated if you're Sicky it's
the best man it's like mother's milk
when you're sick we actually love it we
use it you should use it too I yeah I
got it coming out my ears they keep
sending it to me it's fantastic I love
it I got my friends my family on it we
got it in the studio it's everywhere
there's no artificial sweetener zero
sugar no gluten dairy soy GMOs you're
making a great choice for your health as
well as your hydration uh rehydrate
yourself for the new year grab your
liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free in bulk nationwide at Costco
where you can get 20% off when you go to
liquid iv.com and use the code garbage
to check out that's 20% off anything you
order when you shop better hydration a
day using promo code garbage at liquid
i.com do it this episode is brought to
you by better help gang you're trying to
make New Year's resolutions like workout
and all that stuff how about fixing your
crazy ass [__] brain fix your head
yeah dude I'm all banged up I don't know
what's going on better help can help
instead of sitting in an office talking
to some guy talking to some gal you get
to do it in the privacy of your own home
you get to reach out you get to text you
get to do video you get to do calls
however you makes it easier for you to
communicate and get things off your
chest and help move in the right
direction better help is there for you
yeah uh online therapy it helps you find
the strength you already have to deal
with the problems you have in front of
you you got it in you you just got to
shake the bushes a little bit all nuts
figure out what's out it just helps you
it just gives you tools to deal with
life it ain't it's not going to cure you
it just makes things easier time periods
months days months years it makes all
those things better it's talk therapy is
a fantastic tool and better help has
made it easy to get started which I
think is the best part about this
product you can do it from your own home
you can just sign in If instead of doing
it in person you got to go talk to
somebody he call you back in 3 weeks I'm
not taking anybody you but you've
already waited 3 weeks and you call
another guy he never gets back to you
this you get in the pool and then you
can figure it out get in the pool find
somebody you're looking for a therapist
will'll match you up it's totally online
you can switch therapist at any time for
no additional charge and you can
celebrate the progress you've all by
you've already made visit betterhelp.com
garbage a day to get 10% off your first
month that's better help
hp.com do it all right gang it's a gosh
D Family episode when you sign up for
the patreon we answer your garbage
question on the air uh it's just the
best way to do it we got a lot of DMS
the emails and everything but patreon
gets first crack at it cuz they're the
homies and homies um this one's from
kippy's real dad first time long
time you
stink uh first time long time is it
trash if you ever been bitten by a
groundhog damn oh those things I would
freak out I think oh they they they're
cute I love them I wish I wish they were
friendly just they're not just three
they're very not friendly three more
weeks of winter just for
you six more weeks of rabies is more
like it dude they had those [__]
Chompers in the front we uh we had not
an infestation but they were around one
of the houses my dad it's funny as K
be's real dad this could be my real dad
one of the houses my dad rented like
shortly after the divor like you know
there was a couple years there when I
was uh that was always weird I remember
we were renting houses in the suburbs I
didn't want to say that's a tall I mean
that's in the 9s too yeah we were rent
was multiple like big like family like
you know big houses we were renting I'm
like who owns this are they here they
they living in the other room are they
in the basement I remember the owner we
weren't allowed to have dogs and the
owner would come by Jesus like check in
did you have dogs yeah Patches he was a
[__] he was a hell hound patches just
was and the one anytime we saw I forget
whatever the car was it was like a brown
Toyota or a white Lexus if we anybody I
mean we were you know would the dog let
go in the backyard and stuff what do you
mean like like normally like if the dog
had a poop he had to know you had a dog
I mean he wasn't around I don't know
where he lived but anytime he drove
around like to stop by if something or
pick up mail or drop something off or a
bill or I something see I don't like
that if you're renting a house out pick
[__] rocks don't be showing up
getting your mail no it wasn't like that
you're you got the wrong take on it
wasn't like weekly it was like maybe two
or three times in the three years we
lived there I went around like the
landlord and [__] and uh being he is a
landlord yeah whatever but we had if we
patches get them if anybody spotted the
car we had to get patches in the laundry
room real quick and dude I remember the
one guy he was at the door I'm like yeah
my dad's not here I was like [__] six
I'm like yeah my dad's not dude you just
you can see the laundry room
door like he's just scratching the you
got to do something about these rats in
here by the way you see the nose under
the we're just doing a load of laundry
that's all that's my cousin he's
French he sit down for a couple of days
he's cool though ah he's chill man yeah
yeah had groundhogs but there was a lot
of groundhogs we backed up to not like
what just like a big field kind of like
a basin type thing there was a lot of
you know backed up to a bunch of land
and trees really and uh they were all
back there man and they [__] the dog
would go after them I would sh I'd shoot
at them with my with my little BB gun
they move like when they they wobble
when they're all fat they they move like
that the the real problem with the
groundhog infestation is how you get
Bill Murray out of your
house should I got that going for me I
like them I think they're cute that
little spot behind my mom's where like
the the three uh houses meet there's
then there's two sheds back there and
then you have my deck I remember it
might have been during Co when we were
down there it was like something out of
like a Disney movie they we had like a
fox I started singing and dancing Birds
kept waking me up [__] out of here God
damn it I'm hung over you
[__] knock that singing off the
creatures of the forest helping me with
your day and you're
bized one flies out with a berie the
other's got a lighter
hey thank you the hills are alive with
the sound of
heaters um no we had a fox we had a
family of we had a family of foxes a
little baby one running around and we
had uh some groundhogs and we had some
squirrels and some rabbits and stuff
like that it was all right but then I
think like the lady behind us [__]
didn't like the ground the groundhog
lived there for a while like a couple of
years I think he was renting too
um nothing on me he wasn't allowed to
have a dog and he had
one uh but the lady uh I think uh took
him out cuz he was under her under her
shed I say with that stuff cuz there's a
little patch of wood back there the deer
would come through and stuff like that
it was a nice little
ecosystem yeah but I get you know I love
a fox oh yeah foxes are all right
they're scavengers they're you know
they're you know nah they'll come at you
they'll get the dog and they get ravies
fox fox yeah they come at you no not one
of your dogs your dogs would [__] a fox
up you think so yeah I did all this
research foxes are very small what to
see what hzi can hang stand up against
yeah cuz there's some coyotes and stuff
out there really a little bit I ha [__]
a coyote like they they huntting like
they go after like chickens and like
like or like poodles like there's
Coyotes out there I think a little bit
is there wolves in Utah uh no there's no
wolves uh or maybe it is whatever it is
whatever it said to be in that area I
don't love Coyotes I did the research
and they'll [__] whole they don't
unless they a rabid they're not go
They're not going like a one-on-one with
something that's
like can can hang you know what I mean
they're going after like oh there's aing
cat or a poodle or a squirrel or
something thank going after this guy
who's looking for a b he's at the other
side of the fence like [__] you step on
my property I'm allowed to kill you he
couldn't handle a wolf though right uh I
don't think I mean what wol how big's a
wolf TBO got eyes you got eyes on a wolf
I like a
wolf Wolf's cute you know what else is
really cute baby
raccoon but they get they get rabies 6
feet 70 to 80 80 lbs white males weigh
around 95 to a hundo damn that's an
eighth grader holy [__] yeah a [__]
linebacker bu are smart as shitu Circle
back on you they're devious too they'll
come up they'll be your buddy and then
their homies are in the are in the wings
is that true yes that's how they get
dogs they like they're like hey we're
friends meanwhile they got you know the
boys lurking in in the shadows really oh
yeah you can't trust the wolf son of a
[__] no wolf and sheep's clothing ah
it's pretty good yeah coyotes eat cats
dogs uh yes no yes occasionally coyotes
may mistake small unattended pets for
their prey or attack a large dog if they
view his threats if they're by their den
to keep your cats and dogs safe yeah I
mean like he's in the back there's no
Coyote Den in the backyard so we're
chill nice you got the Hawks down there
too I don't like it um he does I like
the Hawks he runs a tight ship in the
backyard if there's any Critters back
there squirrel man and he they have to
make a the only way out is they make a
beeline it for under the shed and he
knows dude it's game on we got we're
like betting on it and stuff I got
hundreds going who wants it I got I got
20 on CH he's never got
anything but they [__] he hauls ass
after them and man it's a we used to
have it blocked under the shed because I
like I block this so they don't get in
there but then now they can't escape at
all so I pulled them back I go yeah I I
know not just I'm not doing a [__]
Hell in the Cell match here you know
what I mean you got what are you
Commodus and [__] Gladiator no and
sealing off the [__] no I I opened it
up I sealed it off not knowingly and
then I pulled it once I realized oh yeah
I'm not what's underneath that
shed all the animals he hasn't gotten
yet that scar I think they just go out
the back we a rabbit squirrel in the in
the front yard not that long ago maybe
when we were doing the Pod when we first
started doing the Pod I don't know if I
told you about this I it couldn't have
been pandemic it was maybe the summer
before that or was it could have swore
that that that that it was not that long
ago um proper Rabbid squirrel that [__]
scares the [__] out of dude he was they
come up on you he was freaking out
making weird noises we called the cops y
[__] [__] off my property you got your
head out the dooring heat showed up some
rookie pulls his [__] gun on the
thing his is nine I'm okay with it you
GNA tase him you got to put this guy
down dude got a rabbit
animal yeah my neighbor would have knife
through her throat [__] dud let me
see my kids
man give me a helicopter dude we're he
pulls up and like you figure in that
situation they they would go into Animal
Control mode they'd go in the back
they'd get the rifle you know what I
mean or the shotgun or you know what I
like when they when they Tran the Bears
onto the trampoline that's a good time
when the Bear's in the tree in like a
residential area and they Tran them and
[__] catch them and they release them
I love that yeah it's nice n this guy
was this guy was ready to open up on him
drop your weapon I standing right next
to him all right this one's from Durango
why we're on the why we're on the topic
of Annie Ms ever take a picture of a dog
with sunglass on man dogs doing human
stuff is my favorite thing in the world
I you dress a dog up as a guy I'm in
that is the highest level of Comedy I
love the costumes where it has like fake
arms so from the front they look like
Chucky running with dud look like a
little Yorkie dressed up as like the
[__] Batman or something did you ever
see the dog doing
construction it's so good dude he's got
like overalls on he's got like the Neon
shirt oh it's my favorite thing I got to
find it we can pull it up you know what
I really love I love a dog who loves a
slide that's the great they're just
doing laps sure yeah that's fantastic
sure I mean the best one is the pitbull
in the passenger seat and the guy pulls
up and he he looks at him he he's like
you and the dog looks back and like
there he is look at him he's got the
chain on and the shades yeah it's all
that one that guy's great that guy he's
out working dude that guy's doing work
and then this this version of them too
look like Al Reed dude they have them
they have them smoothing
concrete ah you got to put them up man
Ah that's funny that's [__] all dude
dogs doing human [__] sign me up I don't
care the best standup comedy bit the
best movie that will make me [__]
laugh a baby in sunglasses is all right
but it doesn't compare to a dog sure we
um a kitty cat and a sweater is not too
bad either little snuggles you want to
know how trashy my friends are I this is
live this is live update I just got a
text from Pat yo ground Groundhogs Day
is on a Friday this year want to
go to Paton yeah let's do it we should
go it's mad early isn't it oh we could
dress up with the hats and the jackets
and stuff we could go there the night
before and stay over in Paton probably
get a nice breakfast nice little bed and
breakfast or something that's what I'm
talking about that might be all right
when Groundhogs Day it's in February or
something right maybe like early Feb cuz
that's would be six weeks six because
it's about it's about March like if
March is going to turn cold or
not February 2nd February
2nd what how far away is patani patani
it's in it's in PA so four hours no more
it's in the middle of the it's in the
middle of the state I think what's the
scoop that could be a good time that'd
be fun
it's also where my friends are that's
where their head's at 37 years
old he's looking to go to punksatony
Pennsylvania he was probably watching
Groundhogs Day that's what happened he's
probably high on the couch right now 5
hours it's right by Pittsburgh oh that's
a drive that's a drive I'm not flying to
go see a ground dog either I be pretty
fun man stay for the weekend I mean plus
we get to watch it confuse fley for its
dad
wait why I'm not sure I got that cuz you
look like a ground dog okay all right
it's a teeth you were chewing on a lot
of wood with them things them things are
gnarled
down that would be a nice weekend I
think I don't know what the town's like
do they have like a nice steakhouse and
stuff like that P patani by now they
have to why it's one day that's got to
be their whole nut for the year there's
got to be a bunch of restaurants and
[__] out there and some nice bed and
breakfast is and stuff like that I bet
you they do a mean breakfast in morning
Budd I'm looking it's a little guy
nuh-uh there's a municipal airport you
got oo they got they when you search
best places to eat in puxatony PA Taco
Bell and Pizza Hut pop up [__] what are
you doing P Satani Phil's family
restaurant 4.4 Stars 100 thousand over a
th000 reviews okay Frank star lunch
looks all right that's what I'm talking
about you got the new anchor in Italian
restaurant
4.1 got lasz pizza we got punk Satani
pizza looks like they sh man they're
really they're really hanging on this oh
man you got a
Wendy's Puck a Tony filger you got
rumors Tavern oh that sounds like our
kind of spot rumors I don't know one of
the pictures that one of the pictures
come up just a bottle of
ketchup man they should have capitalized
ly I just dude it's a look it's a very
small this is the town that's it it's a
very small town small town so it's like
there's not enough to S sustain a nice
[__] they probably got stuff all
around it this this place looks all
right smok and pet barbecue parentheses
formerly pasqual's Italian restaurant
temporarily closed SL SL
Staples SL FedEx shipping center why
does everything have oregano in it it's
left over from the pizza shop we got got
to get rid of
it uh I mean you know yeah it's it's
slim Pickins out that's a that's small
it's very PL okay Cobblestone hotel and
sweets I'll just watch Groundhog Day an
order in yeah we'll just do that we we
we we live watch it on [__] uh but he
goes and gets the chocolates that he
likes that Diner looks good that dinner
that they have the first night where
where he hits on uh Andy McDow looks
like a nice place where what's his name
has a nice sweater on and then where the
guy chokes that dinner looks good how do
you get into all that stuff we could
probably get VIP access go as media or
something sure that's not Channel 10
news I'm H get an ay news van pull up on
the scene start flexing on those
traditional media
[__] hey Dan Rather kiss my
ass what are you guys shooting on
whatever
dork I just read something um the other
day did you yeah I saw an Instagram
video okay that's reading now no yeah it
is at this point that's you say that you
don't say I saw an Instagram video the
other day you say I read an article the
other day that's the new article in 2024
no yeah no one's reading articles dude a
lot of I think maybe not in our circles
I'm not saying I do don't take this the
wrong way but a lot of people still read
articles give me one place where you can
read an article like what's the trusted
news source oh hey [__] tin foil hat
I'm not saying that any of the news
sources this is you you constantly move
the argument regardless if it's a
trusted news source people are reading
it you know what's not a trusted news
source Instagram yeah random videoos
sent to you by AI you don't know who the
[__] picked or posted what's an what's
what's what's a publication you read an
article in I wouldn't because everybody
lies what about you USA Today that's
pretty good the Daily News Philly Philly
Daily News
inquire I like Mike Lupa M Mike Lupa I
read an article the other day no he
didn't I was reading yeah if I can guess
you were probably watching an Instagram
without headphones in blasting while
other people were around you trying to
do stuff if I can guess that's how you
were reading the article that sounds
about right it [__] drives me nuts
when you do that and the subject of it
was that Ned Ryerson was actually the
devil in Groundhog Day and he was
keeping him
there how about that well then I'm not
going to punk Satani if the [__]
Devil's there all right that guy can
suck my ass I I
H damn all right let's see
here um couple of humdingers already
this one's funny this is from Kyle $10
Homie first time long time never had one
read is it garbage to be voted most
likely to win a hot dog eating contest
in your high school yearbook man you
couldn't have been killing it with the
ladies if that was if they were like
looking at you being like I seen him at
lunch that was just me I seen him at
lunch when there was no money on the
line how do you think this this guy
Russian Texas Tommy yeah this guy this
guy's an earner did you pull any of
those in your yearbook I I don't think
we had them that I think it's Class
Clown or best eyebrows or anything like
that I got biggest eyebrows uh no we
didn't really have that really uh most
like like that I've said this before
very recently all those like tropes of
high school like the 80s and '90s we
didn't have I don't know if like it it
phased out because of like you know did
you have a yearbook yeah of course but
I'm just saying like did people sign
your yearbook yeah of course you had a
yearbook picture yeah senior class quote
I'm sure I did yeah it's probably like a
50 Cent lyric or something if I'm being
hon I have it I can bring it in and we
can we can go over it get rich or die
trying see you [__] [__]
can't stop
me fat ass you hate me now [__] un
tucked white shirt on with a t-shirt
underneath it a big time fitted hat to
match some some baby blue something on
me get C [__] don't get call [__]
walking in the wrong Hood was my [__]
did you hear what happened to kiy on
picture day they shot him nine times
they couldn't get his head to look right
next time I'm next time on my mom's I
know where it is I've seen it I've
recently looked at the yearbook so I
know it's there I don't know if there's
a quote or something I'm might have been
uh we should bring our yearbooks in I
could be a patreon that would be all
right yeah that'd be fun short years is
probably put in the [__] Congress or
something in the the Library of Congress
he was the greatest time in my life keep
it in a safe yeah you probably protected
from fire no I wasn't anything I didn't
get uh best looking or best couple or
anything like that or class Clan or
nothing it would have been the best
couple you in your hand how you
though doing that you're kid I got I got
Pala handerson classic they they did
know my girlfriend Anders that's really
good um they did uh you know what they
thought people were going to become mhm
at like the end of the year book pumping
gas what was yours waiter they nailed
it they said I was going to be an
assistant High School football coach not
even head coach you know you're not you
don't have head coach material you're
not a decision maker they were a bunch
of n too emotional I know the kids that
did it they didn't like me was an inside
job yeah [__] trash
me [__]
[__] didn't even ask me to
contribute I contributed a couple
articles of the school newsp you in uh
did you ever consider running in
anything I did I ran my freshman year
for um 30 to 40
seconds ice cream
truck first day of spring they were
pulling the Tater TOS I had a
move hold on it's in slow
motion
was my whole campaign uhhuh what were
you running for I don't think I ever
knew this Key
Club is that what it's called that's a
thing I never knew what city council no
stud com
troller I play
ball v TR com troller I take PR just
looking down the barrel yeah you're
doing
this money talk going to run this city
honestly for once you're with big
Wing nothing cuts through red tape like
green
bags that's a good
line listen if an I would be disgusted
if $10,000 showed up in my mailbox at
112 Pine Lane I would be
disgusted ah
I find these bribe allegations to be
shocking it was 20s not hundreds I mean
who's got time to count that
much uh it was it was student council
but I thought it was like social
something I never got that I got my
friends had done it you know like think
like like you know not like my super
close immediate friends but like people
we were like friendly with were like in
it like that was like you know it wasn't
like total nerds or anything it was it
was yeah people wanted to do this that's
why I think it was like something social
what whatever the social Department was
like doing [__] like pep rally Party
Committee type thing or something along
I don't know why I think ran the school
store no [__] doing that [__] brick
and mortar I think one of the teachers
if I'm not wrong got caught skimming
from the school store and he got like
his keys taken away from him and stuff
I'm pretty sure that if I'm like I'm for
legal purposes allegedly comedy I think
think that might have happened what
these are all my
erasers you know I just love number two
pencils you know what I used to love at
the school store is one of those grips
for pencils they were like s Square they
were square a that's I wait the little
cubes oh I hated those I like the long
thinner ones the whatever you would put
on the pencil yeah but some there was
like little fat ones that look like a
Dye kind of that would like a Dye like a
like a dice like a Dye yeah yeah yeah
like that they were that shape and size
I like the longer thin ones you get a
real nice hand like were rectangle yeah
they were all right that was all right I
love the idea of all that stuff I could
never put it into practice you know what
the best eraser was did you have a take
on on on pencil erasers of course the
ones like the trian cone ones that would
go on the back wait oh yeah oh the Caps
the little snow caps yeah and they were
like a they were like a pyramid type
thing and there if you had one of those
and a [__] thing and a fresh number
two yeah and you got it down like you
got the little point off and it was a
little round but had the edges man you
could clean this [__] out of a piece of
loose leaf I like the nice eraser like
the the ones that had like the the slope
went up like this and the slope went up
like that the trapezoid yeah those were
all right the idea of all that stuff was
fun but I could never really use it like
I liked all B I liked like the first day
of school I like like the fresh books
and the pencils and all that stuff but I
just you know yeah
wasn't a good student well nether
couldn't do it that's why I was running
for office to try to [__] cook the
book yeah play play ball a little bit
Yeah but I didn't I didn't win I never
got that I remember they going it'll
look good on your res like on your
transcripts and your application was on
my transcripts think I'm going to let
that stop me what nobody checking up on
that this was the '90s there are no
computers yeah what of course um after
school buddies reading to the blind the
whole nine yards I I would have been I
would have been very devious in that
time period without some sort of digital
checkup I would have lied I would have
been principal of my school like I would
have lied about everything you're a
freshman folks as a retired state
senator I feel like I can I'm honored to
be here today I feel like I can really
do a lot for the school district when I
was that would have been Frank abil uh
my my school played so fast and loose
when I was applying for colleges I went
to find out what my GPA is cuz they
didn't give us grades and I was talking
to my like counselor you got a green
this
year and he was like uh you got an all
right man he he is like what's that uh
what do they require I was like I need a
3.5 so what do you think I have and he
was like I don't know
3.9 I like that I like that he's like
what's it out of a 100 what I like when
people play ball a little bit and also
if you look back everybody can play ball
none of that [__] [__] mattered none
of it not just hey just give me what get
why are you going to prevent me from
getting into a better College if you can
what are you doing crazy you're just
being a [__] [__] to be an [__]
oh you're not going to be able to
graduate if you don't do the paper buddy
[__] sign off on it and let me go
fail in the real world what are we doing
here yeah when I FL when I did really
bad my freshman year of college I think
I had like a point two I wasn't going to
be able to play football the next year
unless I got all my grades up to a d so
they brought me in and made me call you
want to be a head coach you got
assistant coach written all over you I
was an English major they brought me in
and made me call every one of my
professors and beg them to give me a d
Everybody did it except for one I dude I
was pumping and dumping on I had two
phones going coffee sir do you have't
minute to talk about penny stock pumping
and d and everybody did it but one guy
and I had to change my major to Hotel
and restaurant management mhm that set
me back a little bit sure I don't know
about 40 years uh um yeah I never had
any of that I was always real big on
like [__] I you know you miss these six
things if you can get six of them in
I'll give you 50% on all of them or
whatever to get me through yeah I never
knew about any of that really I I never
went up to a teacher and tried to like
like barter a little bit like what can I
do to make this up I never did it either
they always they would always say hey if
you have any missed assignments or
whatever I'll give you [__] you
know and you want to make them up it's
theend you're coming on the end of the
school or the end of the quarter or
whatever semester if you want to do them
I'll give you 10 I'll give you 50% of
whatever you do like that's the best you
can get if you turn them in and that's
where I did my best work in those
margins of like I had a c minus or a D+
and I'm like I can get this to a c or a
b and [__] skate through here and
that's how the [__] real world Works
black and white of like there's never
been a problem ever in the history of a
job or anything where they're like
there's nothing you can do to make this
work it's not even it's not even
schoolwork either I you could have got
away with like cleaning the the room or
something like that cutting the guy's
grass I I mean maybe not not not not
back when I was banging huh I was in the
90s it was wide open [__] a couple hand
jobs get you get you [__] on the
Dean's
List always running around a push up
bro washing his car hey
professor bikini car
[Laughter]
wash uh did you ever do that in high
school car wash no did you ever wish did
you ever go like when like if the
cheerleaders were doing like a car wash
did you ever go and get your car wash by
them to support the school I had a 96
Chevy Lumina with the paint peeling off
of it there was no way I was going to go
try to [__] cruise for chicks some dime
bees cleaned at your [__] Arby's
order do you want these french fries
that are under the
sea you're pulling up breakes
[Applause]
screaming
flick a butt out the window and
6 you broads doing huh don't empty my
ashtray I like to keep track I'll be
back in 20 and I'll need a
jump don't turn it
off she pops out of she popped out of
second
gear ah I never had the confidence to
pull into one of those we didn't again
all that stuff stopped happening like
they I mean that sucks we did all that
doing a car that's like you know
I think they realize hey we can't have
16-year-old girls out there [__] you
know a bunch of creeps coming like they
realize that in the early 2000s like
some guy get his garage
night get get in get in yeah yeah I mean
come on what are we doing here yeah they
put an end to that it always gets ruined
that [__] was fun man yeah by perverse
that [__] was fun no we never did
anything like that we never did any like
big fundraiser anything really that I
can that I can think
of uh yeah like I said all those all
those High School tropes from like the
movies and sitcoms we never really had
any of that well bring your yearbook in
we sold popcorn for the Boy Scouts man
the Girl Scouts got the Boy Scouts oh
yeah what what did we know that uh Toby
what when when I was young how young
maybe we might have known this maybe 10
maybe have you told us this I don't
think so you've been [__] how sounds
familiar now you think of it you sold
popcorn yeah caramel cheddar the the
tins oh I'm
listening man come right in young man I
used to crush through that cheddar
square that that cheddar triangle like
ain't no one's B yeah let's go me and my
boy Scott we were in the same troop I
remember we were on the way there he had
his he had his disc man we're going to a
meeting it was the first time I heard
corn blew my mind oh yeah I thought that
was Devil's music man you were right for
the picket little
[Laughter]
rebellious You Were a Boy Scout how long
how long did you make it and did you do
any
overnights uh no and where were the
meetings how was the
sex and are you part of that class
action lawsuit no that's actually why we
stopped my parents like they're
homophobic we don't [__] with them
anymore uh yeah I went uh I'm trying to
think I I wasn't long I was what's a
weea is that a thing you think we're
going to know the rankings a wee below I
don't know I remember that is something
I think I remember I I had the
neckerchief running around like Fred man
where would you wear the uniform just to
there or would you have to wear it like
to church and stuff no no no funerals
for fallen
comrades you had to go notify
people your son has been
molested you're anytime I had to testify
hey they got the Ronnie life weekend I
don't know what
today we're going to take care of the
family Scouts ranks no would you you
only had to wear the uniform Tenderfoot
second class first class star life Eagle
yeah definitely didn't make it the
eagle uh you had to be like 19 to make
it the eagle you don't got the making of
an eagle scout those guys are like
snipers [__] battle they learn they
learn how to sew and help old women
across the street and survive in the
woods yeah I learned how to use a a
flint and steel you know making fire out
of Sparks or whatever huh and selling
popcorn door to door to attain the eagle
rank a scout must earn at least 21 merit
badges fulfill leadership roles and
display outdoor skills demonstrate by
example the Scout Oath and law complete
comprehensive service of the project of
service project in the
community all right hold on what were
the Boy Scouts originally for that's got
to be a World War II
thing I don't I don't I'm not sure why
how they start got to be somewhere yeah
you get the
history um it's got to be somewhere
around there right so there's 13 okay
hold on oh this is I'm in this right
now it started in
1910 World War I I think the beginnings
of it World War I were real weird too
getting ready for the
trenches poor
bastards yeah that probably sucked B
back then there's an American Business
badge closing deals always be closing he
got to sell six
Gars dude we got to get you one of those
kiy what a business badge that's not bad
it's pretty good it's a graph with the
line going up no it's not yes it is
[__] uh archery architecture art that's
sweet archery Automotive Maintenance
what are we doing here in the woods
backpacking I'll give you that canoeing
camping there you go
bugling how you going to how you going
to alert everybody how you going to get
everybody to the battlefield come on the
pedophiles are coming the pedophiles are
coming basketry making baskets you need
that to carry the fish from the
river so basically the scouts were
founded uh at the turn of the at the
turn of the century as people started
moving from farms to cities and then all
these Hillbillies were like they're
they're learn they're not going to have
survival skills anymore so it was a way
to teach the the now Urban urbanized
youth youth about Wilderness exactly
that's pretty good yeah which is so
funny to think it's like dirt roads and
and trains that run on sadness and
they're like we got to teach these kids
how to make
fires cycling's required to be an eagle
scout
cooking drafting electricity these are
[__] whack dude yeah I remember being
bummed cuz they pulled me out right
before I was supposed to go to like the
Sleepaway Camp where you got to shoot
guns no [__] yeah I was 22s I something
small I'm sure but I was I was pissed I
was really looking to shoot some guns
they yanked you huh yep yikes turn in
your uniform yeah they didn't back the
homies dude we had to you know turn it
in I understand is what it is what it is
what it is what are you gonna do shoot
your own guns still haven't dying to
okay I swe have afid weirdo keep an eye
on him hey man it wouldn't be me if it
wasn't weird very he good point debone
um this is from Ethan are you garbage if
you remove the strings from all your
hoodies because they keep dipping in
your food I'm with that I just had this
happen my mine mine never line up and I
can never get them to line up what like
even like you always got a long one
[__] drives me crazy I get it my sou
I'm also peeing on my belt now that's
good cuz it's a it flops open it's right
there it splashes all over me yeah I
yeah I've had that happen before sucks
uh dude I the other day I was I was
doing sets somewhere I went out the
night before I was like sets like Friday
night Saturday night Friday night do
some sets go out have a couple of Pops
afterwards maybe got some Ben's pizza
down there in a village big
deal wake up in the morning I'm like ah
I can wear this hoodie again I didn't
really wear it and I get on and I
realize on stage age it was a black
hoodie with a white string like a fat
white string not like the little like
it's a and I guess piece of Sicilian
hanging off the other side of like it
was had turned man and it was just
covered in red sauce and I was on stage
how you doing yeah it was [__] all
part of the show folks I am a fat slob
in real life yeah suck it off yeah um
all right let's see here this one's from
Uncle zacher um is it garbage to skip
your sister's wedding to watch John Cena
wrestle on pay-per-view PS This was last
October and I'm 29 damn that's nuts
that's [__] up how I mean that's like
got a really [__] with your family why
couldn't you just watch it in the hotel
room and run down there or something I
don't know I mean maybe he really likes
John Cena must that's to me that would
[__] my family up maybe your sister's a
[__] who knows it's also true if
they're not that close and you're like I
don't want to see John Cena just came
out of retirement or whatever who knows
what wedding it is if it's a second is
it a shitty one is it this is there
static [__] that I'm chilling at home
watching [__] John Cena on
pay-per-view I get it maybe you sent a
gift I don't know yeah uh all right this
one's we should stop at Roy Rogers $10
homie never had one red is it garbage if
your dad worked a half a day at his
construction job the day of his wedding
that's that's funny take it day off what
are you doing here that's godamn work I
respect that especially if you're Foo in
the bill you're like hey I got to get
these four hours in there sure you think
it was before or after for the wedding
Oh that's oh [__] has to be before dude
that'd be awesome shows up at the job so
he's got a tux on all right where's my
dammer drill half in the bag eating a
bacon WRA
scallop right let's get this up all
right we got to wrap it up gang gang we
love you to death uh excited for 2024
can thank is enough for everything uh
scoop up the the last of the cards that
are over there at rug garbage.com grab
your uh Second Edition a game and grab
some to come see us at down hall and
eventually we'll be posting the uh the
2024 tour yes we love you and we'll see
you next week peace